sorry my face is tired from dealing with
everything video games are notorious for
having crude mannequin like human beings
if you're playing a game you just have
to learn to ignore it or accept it if
you want to enjoy the game in fact when
a video game has human beings are done
well enough that you can emotionally
connect with them that's considered an
industrywide achievement but we've
discovered a new tool from the VFX world
that when combined with video games
could revolutionize how characters are
rendered wow that was great imagine your
favorite character but as a real person
with a photo realistic
face finally what we are going to show
you is in my opinion the future of video
game Graphics but right now no one has
done it yet so come along as we combine
the world of visual effects and video
games to show you what the future might
look
like so a few years back we used a
machine learning algorithm to turn
pictures of video game characters into
pictures of real people
results were fun but also pretty crude
and kind of goofy and there really
wasn't a way to utilize the tech but now
with the release of stable diffusion XL
which is a new image generation model we
can do much more accurate highly
realistic Transformations so would it be
cool to somehow render a character's
face using just that one image well now
you can there's a new piece of
technology called Insight face from the
company pixie Ai and if you provided a
single image of a face it can morph that
face onto another character using this
process we can turn video game
characters into real people not just an
actor that looks like the character but
an actual true to life rendering of what
that character might look like this
might seem like a deep fake but it's not
a deep fake requires thousands of images
of a person in order to learn what their
face looks like this means that if your
character is purely digital then there's
no living human being that you can just
photograph thousands of times this has
been a problem preventing us from being
able to do this with deep fake
technology ology but the ability to just
use a single frame with Pixie AI
technology eliminates this problem and
the ability to generate a perfect
photoreal image of a character in stable
diffusion XL provides the other very
crucial key to this puzzle so challenge
the gang to take footage from a variety
of games both new and classic to see if
they could visualize what these
characters would look like with photo
real faces all right guys we all split
up we took some time working on this I
want you guys to tell me who this
character is I'm going to pull it up I
want you to guess okay
oh yeah dude it's freaking Ellie
dude aloy aloy that's right this the
original or this is the AI portrait
here's the original y who now let's see
this in
action hold
on before in Meridian you said there was
looks so good holy sh he's gone farl I
haven't heard from him since the battle
against Hades the lip animation still
it's all about that bass animation
falling apart you see that specifically
with the Brows there's this very subtle
furrowing of the Brows you know that
concern these are two different
expressions like the one on the left has
a little bit of like uh sorry for this
next part or is the one on the right is
kind of neutral the cost is just like a
little bit more muted at the benefit of
getting it a little more
realistic who is this Laura Croft nailed
it immediately OG not bad it's not Terri
not terrible but it gives you that
freaking pore detail here which I love
what where are you there she is crusted
up so not as good as the render that we
were looking at earlier man it's a
freaking nobody knows how to animate
lips apparently apparently these people
think lips slide up and down
vertically yeah like that oh no really
I've got to rate this tomb here it is
with the face
morph oh wow that looks great wow yeah
that looks great the shadow of the nose
and the face is really well done like
the way it curves over like the front of
her lips there and stuff mhm that's Kate
beckin stale beckin stale She's Fresh
brother don't we saying stuff like
that who's this oh is this Nathan Drake
whoa that jaw's bricked up son that's so
bricked look at that
thing H that's freaking uh Lisa Lisa
Leslie the girl from Uncharted that's
the girl from Uncharted oh that's Ellie
yeah and now you have a brother oh
that's nice oh wow pretty
dude it's so bizarre seeing everything
being kind of blurry but the faces are
so crisp I don't want to be that guy who
ruins Jameson's early retirement like
that right the eyes lose expressiveness
no one's feeling anything in this scene
the process removes some of the Nuance
from the eye shape yeah it's like they
look more realistic but they don't move
as realistically if they were to make
this technology specific specifically
for this they could just they could work
on just adding more extreme expressions
and you'd be able to represent
Expressions a little more
accurately who's this it's the dude it's
Michael or whatever his name is from GTA
it's Franklin Franklin Franklin
oh that's great dude what the [__]
that's sick who's this oh this is Lamar
Lamar Wow Let's go that's sick don't
hate me cuz I'm beautiful maybe wow that
looks great that one looks great that
one look incredible yeah he looks like a
real person there I wish I could play
the whole game like this who my friends
is this handsome young man oh you did it
yes I was waiting for somebody to do ell
Noir no wow wow Y what a dwee I mean the
the proportions look great in elen Noir
but you know obviously the rendering
quality is not quite the same as an
actual like face morphed I'm sorry to
have to tell you this Michelle but your
mother is dead W dude that's a much
better actor for that character for
her so yeah I mean it works here like
while it's not a perfect fit it
definitely takes it another level who's
this that guy finally dude wow a
Commander Shepherd that doesn't upset
doesn't it oh
God who's this guy it's Conrad I don't
know who Conrad is dude this is Guy
Conrad I'm building an ancient prothean
Dark Energy device to stop the Reapers
oh yes commander commander he looks so
grizzled deep fried man he's the fried
that fell out of the basket to the
bottom of the frer I do like the
original Commander Shepherd a little bit
more I think it shows a little bit more
of like his grizzled commandment you
know like Commandments his Commandments
Shepherd's Commandments I don't know he
just looks too pretty boy on the left
it's like I've I've been noticing that
everyone's lips are the same dude this
guy oh he's so crusty man I don't
remember him being so crusty
that's the biggest glow up I've seen yet
like I've I mean I've played most of the
all the Mass Effect games except for
Andromeda and I it was never like ew
when I'm playing it you just get used to
it but now when we see it like when
we're actually comparing all these
together you really see like the
different strengths of each game here
hey guys so you've probably noticed that
Jake hasn't been in a lot of videos
recently and that's because he's very
busy Jake is a farmer now he has Hogs so
I've actually taken the time to create
Jake's Essence with AI and actually with
these face morphs I think I have the
final tool to fully bring Jake to life
everybody meet Jen Watson Hey Dean it's
me Jake and I'm here to tell you about
today's sponsor
expressvpn so Jake is telling us about
today's sponsor which is perfect that's
Jake's Essence right there so uh Jen
what is expressvpn and how does it
protect my internet privacy well I'll
tell you what Dean not having Express
bpn is like not having a fence around
your crops wow that sounds Terri
terrifying yeah because all the pests
and Vermin they're going to get in there
and they're going to eat all your corn
oh man I think I put too much farmer
into jig expressvpn is the strongest
chicken wire you could ever put in your
garden all these creeps and corporations
are trying to steal your data they're
like Hogs to the slop wow Jake that's a
really good Farm analogy but what if I
have us Netflix and I want to watch a
show that's on Netflix in France or in
the UK with Express VPN I can just
change my IP address to Canada and I can
watch all the Neon Genesis Evangelion I
Ever Wanted oh wow Jake I didn't know
you were that big of an anime fan yeah I
think it's way better than the manga I
mean that is Jake right there so just
head on over to expressvpn.com Corridor
crew and get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn free sorry Jake I got to I
got to go right now please keep talking
to me uh let me just minimize this right
please don't I think I'm going to delete
that model and probably start from
scratch but let's get back to the video
who's this oh that's Starfield lady
right Starfield lady from the
constellation from the constellation
group when you look at what the
character actually looks
like classic Bethesda Bethesda quality
it's not that I don't want to believe in
anything it's that my scientific mind is
often at odds with my spiritual center W
it's like the story's great cool
exploration all that stuff but you know
characters face just have a little bit
to be desired it's like a before and
after meth I think we got to keep this
Bethesda train going here there he
is now him I can get into okay so this
is the before of
Preston dude dude he burned in a fire
it's that radiation man bro it is the
radiation there's a lot of endings to
Fallout 4 but for me the real ending is
when you reach the end of the romance
tree with Preston Garvey you're going to
have to give me a minute to just enjoy
this feeling yeah that's the sound of
elation right there this is like the
perfect use for AI guys it's so it's
like one image to solve so many hours of
gameplay where you have to look at that
sometimes the best use case isn't in
games where you're going to go crazy on
the animation crazy on like the poly
counts the zbrush sculpt of these like
main characters it's like the best use
of this is lots of characters because
when you have a character creation
system like in these Bethesda games like
all the characters are B B on the same
skeleton with the same like facial
morphing things and so that gives you
like infinite varieties so you know
obviously that's hard to make a th000
pictures of an infinite variety of
characters but if all you need is one
like now suddenly this kind of becomes
like the best use case of it where now
any character you create it just makes
that procedural snapshot of them and
uses that for the model now and all the
Bethesda characters are are really
robotic anyway and so you're not losing
any performance you're just gaining
Fidelity so this seems like the
literally the perfect application yeah
so we've showed a lot of ones that are
like very practical like these would
actually work in a real game now I think
we should show some of the other results
that we got that are pretty wacky who's
this uh the
girl from Final Fantasy tfue tfue all
right who's this oh CL oh we got cloud
in
that all right and of course Barrett
Wallace this is the render and this is
my
AI version nice
nice oh wow nice is it nice nice it's
kind of nice tell me she give me
something to hang on to Cloud's giving
me like the Netflix liveaction like
casting Final Fantasy that's the guy
they would cast we got Commander keys
from Halo 1
remastered PR
good that looks like what I remember PC
Gam is looking like but it's so much
better and then dude freaking
Johnson that he got to glow up from that
yeah he really glowed
up nice dude let's go that's oh I would
freaking love this like I'm connecting
with this character right now I'm like
I'm I'm picking up all those emotions
I'm ready to fight dude I want to fight
for him who my friends is this handsome
devil that's agent 74 this is the 47th
one okay this is the OG wow yeah it's
video game model to like a real man it's
giving you subsurface scattering in the
ears I know I know I was shocked by that
crazy super impressive so this is the
game coming out of the Shadows we got
Jason STM baby wow that looks great
there's a speedo under that
suit this is an upgrade this is an
upgrade for sure I would like it if they
put this in the game yeah who is this
handsome devil
wow that beef dude and then we got
freaking sexy Ken dude the Ken we always
wanted
you need to continue your special
training nice wow the
eyebrows that looks pretty great though
it looks good yeah I'm like surprised
dude look at this
guy that's crazy tell me what year this
game is From This Moment has taken some
time to reach us and I imagine you have
many questions good Lord from the year
2033 now the true threat has yet to show
itself I think this is from 2000 or 2001
I think I know what this one is this is
nights of the Old
Republic looks like that dude this is my
favorite game of all time and wow oh
yeah yeah I wanted to test one where we
processed the entire shot like you're
saying Nico we're imagining a future
where you could literally just feed in
one of your favorite old games and like
turn it into like a real shaded version
of it it is unsettling though yeah it's
it's a little weird seeing such like a
hyperreal face on a super low poly
character in background and everything I
can't tell if there's a certain like
animation threshold where it's just
weird having the faces be realistic or
if it's actually better I think this is
the this is the limit there's like not a
lot of key frames here in this animation
you know what I mean favorite little guy
everyone knows him adoring fan our
little boy adoring
[Music]
fan yeah dude that's one of the Paul
Brothers this picture looks nice but
when you we we watch the footage let's
take a look yes oh
great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bye who's this
guy oh no don't do
it you don't have to do no
no that's not that's illegal dude that's
a one to one dude are we allowed to post
what about his
brother yes I love it hey what about his
cousin what about his
cousin is that is thato they related
another the cousin whole body it's his
cousin so Cur yep nice that
was that was beautiful so the big
question is does this feel like a weap
for video game technology like will
people put the effort to put this in
games do you see it having that
potential just seeing this like stable
defusion versions really show you how
much these like portraits and characters
are missing and it's like even though
the the video version like loses the
expressiveness in the eyes like the
rendering quality of them really shows
off like okay we're we're talking about
like the shading of the eyelid on the
eyeball even like the reflection of the
eyelid on the eyeball the eyes just
suddenly look real at the end of the day
that was sculpted by a person and then
textures were laid over it those
proportions are an artist looking at a
person's face and being like I'm going
to get as close as I can but at the end
of the day that that stable diffusion
process just takes those proportions and
just goes and kind of like TI lose it
all together dlss that's like the big
thing right now still AI assisted
upscaling that's happening in real time
and so this is really just like the
smallest step away from what's already
happening with nextg gpus the results
are great the only thing that we saw
cause major problems was those heavy
Shadows cuz we're literally we're
working with like compressed YouTube
clips of the games imagine if this was
on the back end like if you from the
ground up redid the whole inside face
pipeline I I can only imagine be amazing
looking if you guys want to mess with
some of this face morphing technology
the company that has it out right now
that makes it is Pixie pic csi. a so
they actually have a Discord server you
can go there you can load up your own
images your own renders you can do
different like face morphs so big thanks
to them for hooking us up with some of
their like high-end Tech that they have
behind the scenes so we could do this
experiment and yeah we'll have a link to
their Discord down in the description
below this is super cool and we're
putting this Tech to use right now for a
short film that we're going to be
putting out very shortly you know the
words I'm about to say say them say it
they need to hear what if I don't what
if I say it say it say it say it
subscribe oh feels good to
hear h